hey guys it's Candace here in the studio
with Miley Cyrus basically I have some
widely used emojis here we're going to
recreate them okay cool so let's see
this one okay you're like drives a guy
like is this a real smile or I feel like
it like it could be like like uh or it
could just be like I don't know what
that one really is okay let's see this
guy oh here you go
that is pretty good I kind of look like
it okay all right how about this guy
oh yeah that is actually really you I'm
an emoji and finally if they design that
off me okay
how about this one look at all that that
is me I never mind this one's you yeah
that's definitely I oh no okay
you should Oh mmm
how this solid see what else we get oh
that's very hmm do you reuse this one
not that much okay I use the smiles the
rainbow the unicorn the pig the pig okay
yeah I use that after like family
dinners yeah your moji all this one I
need to get my at my tears out I've
adopted us like really cry get them from
Noah yeah yeah this is Noah's I'm okay
yeah it's very cool there you go alright
I think that's it a bit of coal emoji
this is how I feel about mal D being out
Hey that good Ian number two being a boy
I don't want to summer one exactly okay
Miley Cyrus is here Radio Disney
[Applause]